[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
Nats on konnichiwa hello everyone I'm
Yoshiaki Koizumi from Nintendo in this
Nintendo Direct for e3 2019 we'll
showcase a variety of games many of them
coming soon
but before we dig in to the next game
there is someone I'd like to introduce
first what what are you doing here wait
wait wait wait wait a minute
there's been a bit of a mix-up you're
not the right Bowser sorry but I'm the
right Bowser for this presentation not
this way
no no this way Oh bye-bye
maybe next time
are you wasn't related no but we get
that a lot well let's get back to it
please take it away
hi everyone I'm Doug Bowser from
Nintendo of America and I'm thrilled to
join you for today's Nintendo Direct
this is our chance to show the world we
have games for every type of player on
Nintendo's switch whether you love
action RPGs or you're just looking for
something new we've got you covered okay
so let's get a look at one of those
games by taking a tour of Luigi's
Mansion three Luigi's invited to a
gorgeous hotel with Mario peach and the
others oh lucky him
the Luigi's Mansion tree this hotel is
much more than meets the guy for not
long after Luigi arrives things take a
dark turn we begin our tour by taking in
some sights and sounds you may never
leave one to leave the other guests
certainly don't plan to move on their
ghosts after all and their rather
aggressive simply scare them with the
strobe bulb them up Luigi's new
Poltergust g00 has the powerful suction
capabilities required and are the new
features as well
first the slam what rapping it goes slam
it on the ground
inflict some damage it helps to get
other ghosts it on the actual next the
suction shot and find the plunger to
attach it to something then pull the
string and you can destroy furniture and
it's effective against certain co-stars
to
[Music]
sometimes ghosts may feel inclined to
hang up on you
in such situations of first trip to the
powerful air pressure released will blow
away ghosts and it's perfect for when
you need a little air ah we simply can't
overlook the latest invention from
Professor egad namely GUI G change
between Luigi and GUI G to use both
their skills GUI G can do everything
from slipping through metal fences to
walking on spikes
indeed there are obstacles too great for
the region to handle on its own and if
you pass a toy con controller to a
friend he makes for a great co-op
partner but proceed with caution
GUI G and water definitely don't mix now
please direct your attention to the
scare scraper spooky
[Music]
online co-op being defeat all ghosts
before time runs out
seek and find our deal misplaced toes
and face any challenges the tower throws
at you
[Music]
what a place to wake up in a haunted
hotel with floor after floor of oddities
many traps and mischievous toasts
bug within
what will befall our missing Mario and
Friends and his dear brother Luigi rests
in your
Luigi's Mansion 3
[Music]
so that was Luigi's Mansion 3 the latest
game in a series that I personally love
and we can look forward to seeing some
of the new gameplay elements that await
in this strange hotel as we dive deeper
into this title on Nintendo treehouse
live at e3 2019 we'll be streaming
content some you've never seen before
right from the show floor including live
gameplay of Super Mario maker 2 and on
day 3 our treehouse staff will get their
hands on some promising indie games that
are new to Nintendo switch while you
watch today's Nintendo Direct keep an
eye out for this icon to learn what
other games will appear on Nintendo
treehouse live at e3 2019 you won't want
to miss it or this have a look
[Music]
[Music]
avarice unchecked foreign age evil take
salt darkness spreads but from the stock
light brighter than the three suns they
sparked a life
heroes of thrive strong brave strength
and bravery
[Music]
potential
[Music]
yes
[Music]
I'm going to need all that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
action-rpg trials of nana is getting a
global relief under tenderness
[Music]
set destiny in motion
[Music]
trials of mana
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
looking for a woman
[Applause]
you chew
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's all agree to meet back at the
monastery exactly five years from today
like a class reunion you will come won't
you
years ago we fought here as classmates
as big class reunions go this one's got
to be the worst in history what should
we do teachers kill every last one of
them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have no choice but to eliminate those
who cling to unreasonable ideas of
justice
someone must put a stop to this cycle of
a strong trembling a weak
[Music]
star consumers even the doctors say so
yet we have the strength to scale the
walls between us to reach out our heads
friendship so we can open our true
hearts to one another that's how we win
[Music]
both sides of time I reveal to you
[Music]
how lovely it would be for this moment
to last forever
[Music]
wink and I'll say to an 10 dose which is
the only gaming console you can play not
only on your TV at home but anywhere you
go just got there in fact with a system
like this it might be fun to play
Resident Evil at a location like this
this is perfect right
[Applause]
no lights no lights hey we're there
okay let's do this
resident evil
can you open them try Swiss through
there
oh just eat it gonna come back okay okay
okay okay
got it
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Resident Evil playing a Resident Evil
game in a place like that it might not
be my way to play but I bet you could
find your way to play don't you think
for now please take a look was today the
4th of July if not is the Empire
striking back or what looks like things
are gonna get weird today
I see
Jessop
you'd say things got all funky real
quick there's probably some Trinity to
touch dude waiting for me up ahead
Paul yoke and powerful and trying to
take over the world
what there are no heroes in this world
well but they're totally are
Travis touchdown
here to save the world I'm also just a
passing a sad
now let's do this start the game welcome
back brother
to Zagar Delavan
this is Kaiser he led an elite team
contracts during war HP is actually a
cyborg
miss harakiri and her alien gun fight
they survive by merging together during
the alien war
the gentleman the sweetest bug don't
ever meet
[Music]
[Music]
don't give up begin the mission Jer call
rookie
that was already started if you get in
our way we will eliminate
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
konnichiwa hello I'm Shinya takahashi
from Nintendo earlier this month he held
a Pokemon direct for the latest games in
the series I booked him on sword
okay then Pokemon shield the developers
from Game Freak showcased the new
gallery the location of your new
adventure yeah and some new Pokemon
you'll encounter there it will be a
while until these games launch so please
stay tuned by the way in these games you
can use certain functions of the
pokeball plus accessory allowing you to
take a Pokemon from one of these games
out for a stroll through the real world
with you you may not be able to use the
device as a game controller but if you
spend some quality time with a favorite
Pokemon of yours then something good
might happen in the Nintendo booth at
this year's e3 fans can play pokemon
sword and Pokemon shield for the first
time anywhere in the world in this
gameplay demo you can challenge one of
the gems in the gallery region the one
and only water gem where the water type
Gym Leader Nessa will be there waiting
for you if you're attending this year's
show I encourage you to experience
between Dynomax Pokemon it reaches an
advanced strategy from this region
also immediately after this Nintendo
Direct
stay tuned for live gameplay pokemon
sword Pokemon shield on a Nintendo
treehouse live and now I'd like to shift
gears please have a look at this
[Music]
I've been waiting for you
earth is currently under
extra-dimensional de paris like the ones
you've just seen for the first time
[Music]
all of humankind will be pulled into the
cámaras de man
we're facing down we had
don't look
research we finally made it
the ultimate counter chimeric weapon
by neurologically syncing captured
Camaros with human operators
we established control and made powerful
ages
I'll give you some parting advice your
power
nothing you think it is when Oleg
illness and Allegiant are perfectly
synchronized it's like they're two parts
and when half of that body is about to
die
the légion survival instincts kick in to
save it
there's no way what good could this
possibly be
it's a long shot but it's the only shot
we have it's all up to you a friend a
blessing from the legion
a curse
we can't turn back now
I gotta know the whole roof
he's still alive out there
I know he is
you
[Music]
[Music]
the Empire
[Music]
death by our hands is not an honor they
have burned they deserve something much
worse
[Music]
even with this stone at my command
this may not be a battle we can win
whatever is happening we can beat it
keep fighting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so what do you think so far now for some
follow-up information on a game that
fans have been waiting for please take a
look your attention please
the new king getaway package charter
flight will soon be arriving at the
deserted island
[Music]
[Music]
originally we announced this title of a
20-19 release however we need to change
its release date to March 20th of 2020
to ensure that the game is the best it
can be
we must ask you to wait a little longer
than we thought
we hope you look forward to the latest
installment of Animal Crossing now on
Nintendo treehouse live the games
producer mr. Naga me and the director
miss kill Goku will come on for a live
demonstration of some early moments in
the game so please stick around until it
starts by the way there are many
different types of games coming to
Nintendo switch from Nintendo and our
partners so we've prepared a highlight
reel to show you what's in store for
2019 and beyond let's have a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that obviously wasn't duck-hunt
silhouette was it please stay tuned for
more information about DLC in the future
ads for Nintendo switch we have more
games and development beyond what we've
shown you today I'm looking forward to
the day we can introduce them to you
speaking of before we end this direct I
actually have one more thing to show you
thank you very much for watching until
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you